[Music]
lee
is with us in uh huntsville alabama hi
lee how are you
i'm good how are you dave better than i
deserve how can we help
so my husband and i are trying to get
out of our current car loan which we
know
is our dumbest purchase to this point
so we've just had a circumstances of the
change over the last year and a half and
we know that we need to get rid of this
loan
however i've um
spoken about getting a private loan
which i know is that you recommend to
pay the difference for when we sell it
um the loan that i the subprime interest
loan
because we neither of us have great
credit um is
35 for 10 000 for how much
how many dollars ten thousand dollars
holy crap what's your household income
i make 70 a year my husband is currently
has this
we have a circumstance we need a parent
at home at all times with our daughter
so
um i do make 70 we owe 33 on the car
um who said you're 10 upside down
so that is what we've looked at
different
places to buy the car back from us yeah
that's a wholesale buy
i thought okay you need to go to
kellybluebook.com
and look at a private sale where you put
the car up for sale as a
to a private individual you'll make an
extra five thousand dollars on this
transaction
okay see a dealer needs to buy a car at
wholesale or below
in order to put on the market at retail
to make a profit
right so they're not evil they're but
they're bottom dollaring you because
they have to in order to make a profit
and so you know and right now every one
of these dollars is precious
particularly if we start talking about a
35 interest rate so
uh who is the loan with on this debacle
it's ally financial who i spoke with
today
um and
of course they have your current loan
they do have and they're the ones
offering you the 35
no this was with a
different yeah a different rip-off
company so what did ally has allied
quoted
on financing your deficit
um i talked to them about that today and
they said that the only option they have
for us would be a voluntary repossession
no no that's not gonna pay on the ballot
that's not an option
no because they're gonna get it and then
go sell the car for three grand
and then come after you for the
difference for 33 grand
right it might not be three but they're
going to destroy ridiculous
it really is real quick you all didn't
roll over any other prior
loan inside of this new loan did you
no okay all right so this car is not
a 23 000 car this is a 26 or 28 thousand
dollar car
okay and so number one we got to look at
a private sale so now we're talking
about a 5 000
a problem instead of a 10 000 problem
give or take i might be a little off but
i'm not far off
and then you need to keep shopping
because you haven't found anybody that
isn't trying to screw you yet
thirty-five percent yeah so do you have
do you have a local credit union
we do have you tried them i have not
tried them yet
and listen don't call them on the phone
if they're open and taking customers
where are you
in huntsville they might be open if
they're open and seeing like human to
human interaction and all
go sit down in person show them what
you're doing
and that you're moving this is not just
a loan to go on vacation or something
this is a loan to clean
we're reducing our household debt from
33 to six
by doing this or whatever the number is
right and so i just need a small
personal loan
uh and then i'm going to i'm making 70
and we're going to get it paid off
really fast you know that because we're
already paying a 33
000 car payment yep and they may require
that you put
500 in and start a checking account and
it's sitting there
but i love dave's advice of you going in
because now you become a human
yeah with a story and a process and a
plan
and leah i thought that can go well for
you yeah because i can't imagine the guy
offering you 35
did that in person no
no no that was over the phone email no
no you
could just be hard to look somebody in
the eye say 35 i wanted to put my hands
up in the air
what she said